i think you're just focusing on too much  visible assets i often talk about  invisible assets that could be your  youth your energy and also your friends  and your ideas  and uh your heart  you know um we just um  unfortunately we value  how much money you have in your bank  account or how many how how  how you own things  but in life there are so many invisible  assets that you can count on so instead  of having so much money in your bank  account  if you have 10 good friends  who just let you stay for a week or so  you can keep on living you know i the  other day i wrote down how many friends  i have and then i realize i have more  than 50 friends  who can just you know feed me for a week  so you just keep visiting your friend  every week until the next year comes so  you know you can live off of your  friendship for a year  that's financial independence